democrats now openly wishing that trump
dies
zara rahim a former obama official who
also worked on clinton's presidential
campaign
hillary not bill she tweets out
after the president was diagnosed quote
it's been against my moral identity to
tweet this for the past four years but
i hope he dies and then she's got little
stars around the dies
die scope imagine saying that imagine
saying that about a fellow person
and this is not just some low-level
staffer right this is
an obama administration official and a
high-level clinton presidential official
imagine if any republican said this
about a democrat
about that about the democratic
president about barack obama can you
imagine be wall-to-wall coverage this
probably your only hearing on this show
max berger former staffer for elizabeth
warren
i can't think of anything more
distasteful than wishing death upon
another human
except maybe causing preventable mass
death because you don't want to damage
the stock market
or your re-election chances all jokes
aside i hope the president injects
himself with bleach
it's a liz warren staffer by the way
when these people say that trump has
made the virus worse and he caused
preventable mass death
ask him how ask those people
how did he do that what did he do as far
as i can tell people are mostly trying
their best
in this country even the governors and
the mayors they're trying their best
some have
way overreacted but they're trying their
best to protect public health
and most of the policy decisions are
defensible
with one exception andrew cuomo in new
york sending sick people into nursing
homes
that one is absolutely indefensible
andrew cuomo the democratic governor
darling of the democratic party
does have to come to account for that
other than that
i don't see any example anywhere in the
country but they're convinced trump is
killing people
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
you